member is on the line in Oklahoma hi
amber how are you I'm good mr. Ramsey
are you better than I deserve what's up
in your world well I kind of need some
man advice my husband has been in this
job that he's in for about six years
it's oil field so it's changed hands a
bunch of times and if you know anything
about oil field areas it's kind of a
toxic environment and an unsure
environment as far as job security yep
it's really hard work it's a really
rough situation and you don't know
what's going to happen it's a volatile
volatile career path but you make a lot
of money yeah
well that's where our predicament is my
husband is kind of given up on being
able to find anything outside of
oilfield
where we live it's small town I'm sure
you understand everybody knows my
husband's name everybody likes him
they'd hire him in a minute he's
hard-working
I mean dedicated as can be but what's he
making here um about 50 okay he's a high
school graduate or a college graduate
associate's degree okay and what I just
general education old is he he is 31
what you want to be doing when he's 41
the page 50,000 that's not the oil out
that's where I've been trying to get it
out of them I don't think he really
knows other than just just day-to-day
where he wants to work hard but he wants
to go home see his kids not have to
worry about tomorrow not have to deal
with you can do all that if you discover
thereíre though you make money yes all
you gotta do I mean this I want I want
to be a whole life I want to be home is
not the goal here the goal is have a
good career and be making some money and
then you can go home yeah you don't have
to work one thing I want for him
and I think he likes the idea that is
there's a an old business in town he
used to work for the man who owned it
just a tire shop and I'd love her to be
able to you know own a business and him
be able to just work his day today but
on in a business that you don't like
harder than working for toxic people yes
you own your own business your bosses a
but yes he will drive you into the
ground trying to make that thing
successful and so you better love what
you're doing when you own your own
business and just buying a tire shop
just because it's your own business is
not a plan you need to have a plan that
involves him owning a business doing
something he loves yeah I think that's
the thing for him is he's still just
trying to tread water no but here's the
thing you need to figure you all need to
sit down on the back porch for the kids
in bed cold cup of coffee or something
else and sit there and look out at the
sunset and say gosh when I'm 41 what do
I want to be doing if I could do
anything I want to do which by the way
this is America you can do anything you
want to do now then what steps have I
got to take oh we can't do it in a small
town we got to move okay
oh I've got to have some more training
on that area okay oh we are gonna save
some money and get out of debt okay but
if you can lay out what has to be true
that's not true today in order to be
doing that 10 year that thing ten years
from now then the thing starts to open
up because if you say it you know what
if I had it you a million dollars and I
said now go do anything you want to do
that's the way you ask the question do
anything you want to do do anything you
here's a million dollars go do anything
you want to do but you have to have a
career making money you're not gonna sit
on your butt and catch the million
dollars that's not the point the point
is you don't to worry about money so
what are you gonna do anything you wear
there are no barriers you can use the
million dollars to create whatever
career you want to create okay then go
do that I'm not gonna give you me in
dollars to do that but if you wanna
start thinking that way it opens your
brain back up instead of going well the
little moon good hood and all
guys at work say well the guys at work
are stupid listen all the guys at work
they're at work you know you need to
have a plan that says I'm gonna live the
dream so hang on I'll send you a copy of
Ken Coleman's book the proximity
principle oh and throw in that book
called start because this guy needs to
start